the four valves in your heart keep your
blood flowing forward located between
your left atrium and left ventricle your
mitral valve controls the blood flow
between these two chambers and stops
blood from flowing back into the left
atrium when the left ventricle contracts
the mitral valve is composed of a front
portion known as the anterior leaflet
and a back portion known as the
posterior leaflet a fibrous ring of
tissue called the annulus surrounds the
mitral valve this maintains its shape
and helps ensure that the leaflets
closed completely tendinous cords anchor
the leaflets to small projections in
your left ventricle called papillary
muscles if you have mitral valve disease
your posterior leaflet enlarges and
projects or prolapses into the left
atrium
this may result from your cords along
gating or rupturing the damaged valve
allows blood to leak or regurgitate back
into your left atrium the only way your
left ventricle can compensate for this
condition is by enlarging and pumping
more volume this causes your mitral
orifice to enlarge preventing your
leaflets from closing properly to treat
this condition your doctor may suggest a
type of minimally invasive procedure
called robotic mitral valve repair your
surgeon will begin the procedure by
making five small incisions on the right
side of your chest a second surgeon will
insert a special camera called an
endoscope and other tools attached to
the robotic arms through the incisions
these robotic instruments allow the
surgeon a wider range of motion and more
precision than the normal human wrists
in order to perform your operation
safely the surgical team will stop your
heart and place you on a heart-lung
machine this machine takes over the
functions of these organs during your
operation a tube called a cannula will
be inserted into your right groin
draining blood from your heart into the
heart-lung machine
the machine will oxygenate your blood
and pump it back into your body through
another cannula inserted through a small
incision in your left groin seat it at
the robotic console your surgeon will
operate the robotic arms and the camera
with hand controls and foot pedals this
computerized system will translate the
exact movements of your surgeons hands
into precise movements of the robotic
instruments
your cardiac surgeon will have a
magnified 3-dimensional view inside your
body through a high-definition binocular
display your surgeon will then make an
incision in your left atrium to get to
the mitral valve there are different
types of repairs depending on the
condition of your mitral valve a
posterior leaflet repair is one of the
most common types during the repair
process your cardiac surgeon will most
often remove part of the prolapsed
portion of your valve and will suture
together the remaining tissue your
cardiac surgeon will also correct the
enlargement of the mitral orifice by
suturing a firm band or ring to the
mitral annulus robotic mitral valve
repair is the least invasive and the
most precise technique available to
treat mitral valve disease the benefits
for patient include no splitting of
breastbone less pain because of no
retraction of the chest wall lower risk
of infection and bleeding allows for
high precision complex mitral valve
repair shorter hospital stay quicker
recovery and return to activity and
significantly better cosmetic results
for more information contact
cardiothoracic surgery
at NYU Langone Medical Center cardiac
and Vascular Institute 2 1 2 2 6 3 2 3 2
9